[Music]
sometimes
life can be an uphill battle i just want
the
peace in the world that's all i want
adversity can take a lot of different
shapes and strike at
the most inopportune times i came into
this tournament with my father
uh yeah he passed away just before i got
here and his last wish was that i
i went here and so i really want to
dedicate this one to my father
but the real test of character lies in
how you respond to the challenges that
life throws at you do you see hardship
as a punishment or as a way to motivate
yourself to
do and be better and once upon a time
jacob pimpwanek had to make that very
choice
i was the guy that people would point
towards you would be like you'd be
seeing me on the street and you'd be
thinking to yourself
oh i feel so sorry for that kid he's
gonna have a miserable life
but rather than allowing himself to be
overcome by his problems
pimp used them as a launching point to
accomplish what he himself calls his
life's
greatest achievement and i'm not even
talking about his professional cs go
career
or his successful full-time stream
so what exactly motivated pimp's insane
transformation and what's more how is he
using the adversity he overcame
to help others cope with their own
struggles i would
love to take the the opportunity to to
inspire people who are
either in a very young age who haven't
gone through all the stuff that they
have to go through or
people at my own age who just need that
little extra kick in their butt to get
going
[Music]
okay so anyone who is actually familiar
with pimp's stream knows that
it's a lot like counter strike itself
things don't always go according to plan
in fact they usually don't it's fresh
out like that so if there's a scout on
avp you don't die you jump up like this
hit the flash right there it's gonna
bounce over here and you are getting
what
get them we're gonna have to forget
about check it out
oh we're playing against the worst [ __ ]
noobs
oh my god can i be any more unlucky nice
can i be any more unlucky but while some
of pimp's lessons do
occasionally blow up in his face he has
been able to find success in every other
area of his life by putting in the hard
work
whether it's by playing his heart out as
a pro cs go
player how could it be it's just a ump
but he's gonna be walking up
pico going down pimp gets one and a
follow-up crew
he's out with the triple kill
asking the tough questions as an analyst
how much time a day do you spend doing
your hair
it's like five minutes in the morning
five minutes yeah it's fast or dropping
a whopping 130 pounds of weight that had
been interfering with his
life since he was 11 years old if i were
asked five years ago would you
you stay at 130 kilos and be a top five
player in the entire world for for the
next five years
would you like to lose 60 kilos and you
know see where it takes you and i kind
of promise you what happens i would
100 do the same as i did you know i
would lose the weight and
i would see where life would take me
like a lot of kids growing up
pym spent most of his early years
playing a variety of different sports
i've always been very interested in
football always been very interested in
doing sports in general biking cycling
all that kind of stuff
but at some point the siren song of junk
food and video games
turned a once active kid into an
overweight teenager who struggled with
the most basic forms of physical
activity i remember that our classroom
was on the second floor which means that
i had to walk up
four different staircases to go to our
classroom and i was
so afraid that every single time that i
would enter my classroom my back would
be all sweaty
you know so you could see that i've been
sweating just because i have to walk up
the four staircases because i was
sweating you know there's no hiding
there and so
pimp poured hours and hours into
counter-strike
cutting his teeth in source before
becoming an established pro player in
global offensive
good coordinated attack this one and uh
here they come in fact pimp
drops down forest he's in a really good
position here to pick up a second and
does so
and a third is it not quite will he get
into the attempt yes he will
triple from pip team health
and he's up against get right as last
man's name
and wow
what an amazing round from pip now from
the outside
pimp appeared to be living the dream
clicking heads for paychecks but
on the inside the truth is that he was
struggling to find happiness
try imagine having a life where you
constantly walk around
and the only thing you think about is
how do i hide the fact that i'm
as big as i am how do i make sure that
no one else feels uncomfortable around
me
because i don't feel comfortable around
myself you know and it was around the
time that pym
turned 18 that he decided to make some
serious changes to improve his life
outside of the server
he realized that he wasn't going to find
happiness in
sugar and salt so he decided to knuckle
down
and get serious about nutrition now of
course
salad alone wasn't going to fix the
problem so him started spending all of
his free time
getting into shape even when training
proved detrimental to his gaming career
i was over training and and i overworked
my
my bodies as i was dealing with some
tendonitis in my arm i think it was two
or three weeks where i
i barely practiced i was only part of
the practice but i never played outside
of practice
i didn't play that match didn't play
anything it was a constant learning
experience and at some point you just
overstepped that market
and of course had to take the
consequence of but even when his
performances weren't blowing them away
fans became mesmerized by the very
public
transformation he was undergoing and
they weren't the only ones to notice
just how far pimp had come since making
that fateful decision to turn his life
around
my dad passed away unfortunately two
years ago and
and if you asked him you know what he's
the most proud of about his son i don't
think he's the most proud of him being a
professional counter-strike player he
was proud of that he
couldn't stop telling his friends that i
made a living of playing counter-strike
but
if you had to pinpoint one thing i am
100 sure that he's proud of the
transition i had
going from being a very uncomfortable
guy to to be around and a very
uncomfortable guy
in my own body to be a guy that is
filled with excitement for life that is
filled with
with energy that is filled with all the
stuff that i'm i'm filled with you know
eventually after hitting a career high
with team liquid and becoming a streamer
for dignitas
pimp decided to step away from
competitive play for
good in 2020. instead he became more
focused on
self-improvement and devoted his time to
honing his skills as an
analyst and as an uncannily unlucky
content creator
smoker made like this you actually need
two flashes right i'm just gonna do one
though
[ __ ] should work okay
every time i do something why does that
stuff happen so you made him this window
you just get ready right here if this
guy down
see that's the first time that ever
happened here's another trick dress like
this
and everyone out here is mine beside
that character she's not blind
but as they say even a broken clock is
right twice a day
i'm gonna do a little trick okay you
smoke up like this plastic like this
twice
you go with the flashes rush through the
smoke
go around like this and if you're lucky
there's gonna be a guy right here
standing
trick for you guys now you might think
that staying home in front of the
computer and
streaming all day would derail pimp's
commitment to fitness
but nothing could be further from the
truth if anything twitch has not only
inspired him to crank it up a gear
but it's given pimp a more direct route
to helping those in need
although he remains adamant that the
motivation to change one's life
must come from within it has to come
from within right you have to find out
what is your motivation why do you do
what you do if you just look at yourself
in the mirror and you think
it'd be nice if if i lost five kilos and
you don't really know why you don't
really know what
change it'll make for you then nine out
of ten times i'll argue you're probably
not going to be successful with it so
if you find enough enough motivation if
you surrender
a strong enough course to to do what you
want to do then
you will have a higher chance of being
successful and these days with everyone
locked in their houses and running low
on motivation because of the global
pandemic
pimp's fitness infused positive brand of
streaming
has only increased in popularity started
to do push-ups on the screen
started to do like small fitness
sessions on the stream especially during
covet because i felt a lot of people
were using the excuse that
okay now we're in a lockdown fitness is
closed all around the world so now we
can't exercise and that was like
they gave themselves an excuse of not
doing it whereas i can stream i can play
a game of counter strike and you can
make a deal that says for every kill i
do one push-up
for every death i do one shot or
whatever that may be right i'm so good
at this game
it's ridiculous let's [ __ ] win now
boys that hand up
let's get it going help out gaming
coming in with us up dropping it in the
chat
i owe you 35 push-ups let's go boys
perhaps the strangest aspect of pimp's
story is the fact that while
gaming and esports may have enabled his
unhealthy lifestyle to begin with
that same innate drive that led him to
go pro
is ultimately what helped him get his
life back to where he wanted it to be
if there is anything to be learned from
pimp's incredible transformation
it's that change is inevitable and that
at the end of the day it's up to us to
decide whether that change is going to
be for the better
or for the worse i've been the big guy
i've been the healthy guy
when i'm done playing counter-strike
when i'm done streaming when i'm done
you know doing all the stuff that i have
goals in right now
i wouldn't mind being a guy who who
dedicated my life to help others to
achieve some of the stuff that i've
achieved
because i can like bother my heart say
that this is this is one of the best
feelings that i've ever had you know if
this is one of the most pride feelings
i've ever had you know pimp's story
reminds us that you can refuse to
surrender to the travails of your
personal life
and even turn them into a beacon of hope
for others who may be struggling as well
all it takes is some dedication
self-belief
a lot less junk food and of course
just a little bit of patience i hope
that i've
played just a tiny tiny part or a small
small part
in hopefully pushing you in the right
[Music]
direction
okay okay guys
matt honestly man i with that i think i
tried to no scope
i think i actually like didn't even i
think that's why it whiffed like it went
because i tried to no scope you
who's last uh matt i think matt maxie
how